الفعل في يوم ماطر انهمرت الاخبار السعيده
على النصراويين وكذلك كل مشجعي ومحبي كره
القدم في السعوديه بهذه الصفقه الكبيره
التي تعد من او الاكبر على مستوى الدوري
السعودي في طوال تاريخيه تتواجد نجم عالمي
واسطوره من اساطير كره القدم يتواجد في
الدوري السعودي في الحقيقه الترقب كبير
جدا لاول مباراه سيلعبها كريستيانو
رونالدو في الرياض بالتالي بدا الحديث
بشكل واسع عن همم التذاكر لاول مباراه
سيلعبها كريستيانو في الرياض في الدوري
السعودي وايضا بدا الحديث يتداول عن متى
همم وصول همم موعد وصول النجم البرتغالي
الذي سيحط رحاله في الرياض في الحقيقه
هنالك ايضا اخبار اخرى همم تصريحات اخرى
واخبار بدات بالتوافق بعد الاعلان عن
الصفقه بشكل مباشر عن احتفاليه ضخمه ستكون
في بدايه همم
طول كريستيانو رونالدو احتفاء ان به
وبوصله الى السعوديه وكذلك همم اللاعيبه
في الدوري السعودي ستكون هذه الاحتفاليه
ربما بعد همم بعد وصوله مباشره في احد
المواقع الرئيسيه ربما يكون هناك في احد
او ملعب نادي النصر مرسول بارك همم سيكون
هنالك اعلان بتفاصيل اكبر عن هذه
الاحتفاليه لكن طاهر يعني انتقل مباشره
الى الاجواء في الشارع السعودي بعد
الاعلان عن هذه الصفقه والردود الافعال
سواء كان من النصراويين او حتى من مشجعين
الانديه الاخرى شهاده ردود فعل واسعه من
كافه المشجعين في مختلف همم الانديه
الاخرى همم نرحب فيك اليوم كيف تشوف هذه
الصفقه وانعكاساتها على الدوري السعودي
وايضا شخصيا كيف تشوف تواجد كريستيانو
رونالدو في همم في السعوديه والدوري
السعودي اول همم اداره النصر للجمهور هذه
الصفقه الجميله وهي سبلانا حنا كا انديه
سعوديه وغير كذا مكسب لكريستيانو في اهداف
اكثر همم وعلى هلالي صراحه بس يعني اشكر
ان شاء الله اداره النصر عن الشيء اللي
سووه
بيكون كبير الان بين الهلال والنصر بعد
وصول كريستيانو والله شوف هو لاعب واحد ود
وحده متصفق لكن ان شاء الله نقول نقدر ان
شاء الله على نادي النصر
انت كيف شفت خبر انضمام كريستيانو رونالدو
الى همم نادي النصر
وتواجد في الدوري السعودي بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
لاعب همم امكانيات عالي يكون مثل
كريستيانو رونالدو في همم في السعوديه
وبالذات في نادي النصر ما نبي نصراوي
الامان صفقه عظيمه بالنسبه للنصر هذه من
اكبر الصفقات العظيمه والجميع السعوديين
يعني بشكل عام يعني كل المفروض
كريستيانو في الملعب
في عمليه ردود الافعال في الشارع السعودي
اليوم همم شاشه العربيه اليوم كريستيانو
رونالدو اعلن الرسميا بانه سيكون في
الدوري السعودي كيف تشاهد هذه الصفقه كم
متتبع للكره السعوديه في اا في الدوري
السعودي وايضا حتى على مستوى تاثيرها على
الاقليم اولا الله يسعد مساك والله يحييك
والحمد لله اليوم اجواء كلها خير والحمد
لله اخبار ساره نادي النصر تعاقد مع
اللاعب الكبير كريستيانو رونالدو وهذا
اضافه همم
الوطن للسعوديه اول شيء والنادي النصر
الكبير والحمد لله هذا حلم متحقق وان كان
يقول الحلم والحمد لله الحلم انت تحقق
الحمد لله تنتظرون كريستيانو فتره طويله
يعني والله الحمد لله اللمبات كثير والحمد
لله ما قصروا اداره نادي النصر والله
يسدهم زي ما يسعد جماهير نادي النصر و
رونالدو لاعب كبير الحمد لله كبير والنصر
الحمد لله
حتى تواجد في المباراه الاولى لكريستيانو
حتى تحرص على شراء التذكره من الان باذن
الله في كل مكان يلعب نادي النصر متواجد
باذن الله والف شكر نادي النصر والف الف
مبروك لجماهير نادي النصر العالمي والله
انه بدايه خير باذن الله شكرا لك يا حبيبي
ودي احتفاء كبير جدا بالرغم من زخات المطر
التي لا تزال تتواصل في الرياض منذ الصباح
وحتى الان وطقس همم البارد الا انه البعض
همم خرج الى المقاهي الى الاماكن العامه
ليتداولوا الحديث حول هذه الصفقه الكبيره
التي تم الاعلان عنها قبل قليل وايضا
عمليه ترقب ل- اا وصول كريستيانو رونالدو
ومباراته الاولى ايضا مع النصر